sigh here he come for Sultan pops the
moment of his life
[Applause]
good afternoon I have just been to see
her Majesty the cream who has invited me
to form a government and I have accepted
I pay tribute to the fortitude and
patience of my predecessor and her deep
sense of public service but in spite of
all her efforts it has become clear that
there are pessimists at home and abroad
who will think after three years of
indecision that this country has become
a prisoner to the old arguments of 2016
and in this home of democracy we are
incapable of honouring a Democratic
mandate and so I am standing before you
today to tell you the British people
that those critics are wrong the
doubters the doom stirs the glue stirs
they are going to get it wrong again the
people who bet against Britain are going
to lose their shirts but their's willing
to restore trust in our democracy and
we're going to fulfill the repeated
promises of Parliament to the people and
come out of the EU on October 31st no
ifs or buts and we will do a new deal a
better deal that will maximize the
opportunities of brexit while allowing
us to develop a new and exciting
partnership with the rest of Europe
based on free trade and mutual support I
have every confidence that in 99 days
time we will have cracked it but you
know what we aren't going to wait
99 days because the British people have
had enough of waiting the time has come
to act to take decisions to give strong
leadership and to change this country
for the better and though the Queen has
just honored me with this extraordinary
Office of State my job is to serve you
the people because there if there's one
point we politicians need to remember it
is that the people are our bosses
my job is to make your streets safer and
willingham in with another twenty
thousand police on the streets and we
start recruiting forthwith my job is to
make sure you don't have to wait three
weeks to see your GP and we start work
this week with twenty new hospital
upgrades and ensuring that the money for
the NHS really does get to the front
line my job is to protect you or your
parents or grandparents from the fear of
having to sell your home to pay for the
costs of care and so I am announcing now
on the steps of Downing Street that we
will fix the crisis in social care once
and for all with a clear plan we have
prepared to give every older person the
dignity and security they deserve my job
is to make sure your kids get a superb
education wherever they are in the
country and that's why we have already
announced that we're going to level up
per pupil funding in primary and
secondary schools and that is the work
that begins immediately behind that
black door and though I am today
building a great team of men and women I
will take personal responsibility for
the change I want to see never mind the
backstop the buck stops here and I will
tell you something else about my job it
is to be Prime Minister of the whole
United Kingdom and that means uniting
our country answering at last the plea
of the Forgotten people and the left
behind towns by physically and literally
renewing the ties that bind us together
so that with safer streets and better
education and fantastic new road and
rail infrastructure and full fibre
broadband we level up across Britain
with higher wages of higher living wage
higher productivity we close the
opportunity gap giving millions of young
people the chance to own their own homes
and giving business the confidence to
invest across the UK
because it is time we unleashed the
productive power not just of London and
the southeast but of every corner of
England Scotland Wales and Northern
Ireland the awesome foursome that are
incarnated in that red white and blue
flag who together are so much more than
the sum of their parts and whose brand
and political personality is admired and
even loved around the world for our
inventiveness for our humour for our
University's scientists our armed forces
our diplomacy for the equalities on
which we insist where the race or gender
or LGBT or the right of every girl in
the world to 12 years of quality
education for the values we stand for
around the world every not everyone
knows the values that flag represents it
stands for freedom and free speech and
habeas corpus in the rule of law and
above all it stands for democracy and
that is why we will come out of the EU
on October the 31st because in the end
brexit was a fundamental decision by the
British people that they wanted their
laws made by people that they can elect
and they can remove from office and we
must now respect that decision and
create a new partnership with our
European friends as warm as close and as
affectionate as possible and the first
step is to repeat unequivocally our
guarantee to the 3.2 million EU
Nationals now living and working among
us will I say directly to you thank you
thank you for your contribution to our
society thank you for your patience and
I can assure you that under this
government you will have the absolute
certainty of the right to live and
remain and I say next to our friends in
Ireland and in Brussels and around the
EU I am convinced we can do a deal
without checks of the Irish border
because we refuse under any
circumstances to have such cheques and
yet without that anti-democratic
backstop and it is of course vital at
the same time
that we prepare for the remote
possibility that Brussels refuses any
further to negotiate and we are forced
to come out with no deal not because we
want that outcome of course not
but because it is only common sense to
prepare and let me stress that there is
a vital sense in which those
preparations cannot be wasted and that
is because our under under any
circumstances we will need to get ready
at some point in the near future to come
out of the EU customs union and out of
regulatory control fully determined at
last to take advantage of brexit because
that is the course on which this country
is now set with high hearts and growing
confidence we will now accelerate the
work of getting ready and the ports will
be ready and the banks will be ready in
the factories will be ready in business
will be ready and the hospitals will be
ready and our amazing food and farming
sector will be ready and waiting to
continue selling ever more not just here
but around the world and don't forget
that in the event of a No Deal outcome
we will have that extra lubrication of
the 39 billion pounds and whatever deal
we do we will prepare this autumn for an
economic package to boost British
business and to lengthen this country's
leave as the number one destination in
this continent for overseas investment
and to all those who continue to
prophesy disaster
I say yes there will be difficulties
though I believe that with energy and
application they will be far less
serious than some have claimed but if
there is one thing that has rarely
sapped the confidence of business over
the last three years it is not the
decisions we have taken it is our
refusal to take decisions and to those
who say we cannot be ready I say do not
underestimate this country do not
underestimate our powers of organization
and our determination because we know
the enormous strengths of this economy
in Life Sciences in tech in academia in
music the arts culture financial
services it is here
in Britain that we are using gene
therapy for the first time to treat the
most common form of blindness here in
Britain that we are leading the world in
battery technology that will help cut
co2 and tackle climate change and
produce green jobs for next generation
and as we prepare for a post brexit
future it is time we look not at the
risks but at the opportunities that are
upon us so let us begin work now to
create free ports that will drive growth
and thousands of high-skilled jobs in
left-behind areas let's start now to
liberate the UK's extraordinary
bioscience sector from anti genetic
modification rules and let's develop the
blight resistant crops that will feed
the world let's get going now on our own
position navigation and timing satellite
and Earth Observation systems UK assets
orbiting in space with all the long-term
strategic and commercial benefits for
this country let's change the tax rules
to provide extra incentives to invest in
capital and research and let's promote
the welfare of animals that has always
been so close to the hearts of the
British people and yes let's start now
on those free trade deals because it is
free trade that has done more than
anything else to leave billions out of
poverty all this and more we can do now
and only now at this extraordinary
moment in our history and after three
years of unfounded self-doubt it is time
to change the record to recover our
natural and historic role as an
enterprising awkward-looking
and truly global Britain generous in
temper and engaged with the world no one
in the last few centuries has succeeded
in betting against the pluck and nerve
and ambition of this country
they will not succeed today we in this
government will work flat-out to give
this country the leadership it deserves
and that work begins now
thank you very much
[Applause]